(delicate haunting music)
- [Narrator] To wander this
mausoleum in Shiraz, Iran
is like stepping into the
holiest of light shows.
The Shah Cheragh which roughly translates
to king of the light in Persian.
Is a funerary monument and mosque,
a beautiful holy place for
thousands of Muslim worshipers.
The structure is made
of multi-colored pieces
of tile and glass and is considered to be
the third most important
pilgrimage site in Iran.
Initially started around
900 A.D. as a burial site
for an important Shia Muslim figure,
the mosque continued to
be expanded and improved.
The decision to adorn the mosque
with its iconic mirror ball decoration
came from Queen Tash
Khatun in the 14th century.
She wanted the mosque
to intensify any light
a thousand times over, an
homage to the mosque's name.
Although meant to be a holy shrine
and important pilgrimage
location for Shia Muslims,
people of any faith can marvel
at the mosque's immense beauty.
(tone rings)